hey guys i'm here with us champion you
karnak more after another tough loss
tell us what happened today guri said
they may be were affected by yesterday a
little tired is that true uh yeah I mean
obviously yesterday was was you know not
the best day certainly especially the
fact that i had a draw right at the end
and i missed it um but you know that
really didn't have that big effect what
happened today was simply i miss assess
position i thought that i was a little
bit worse when it's probably completely
equal when i tried to force things
because i thought i had to go for
counter play and essentially it just
came down to this idea of you know when
I neesh was able to get this Bishop to
be seven before i got my night to d5 and
I just basically I I didn't sense the
danger I thought that it was all
relatively ok and and maybe it was but
it was a little bit unpleasant and and
by the time that I realized that it
could be quite bad it's already much too
late in a you know just you know things
happen know if this London chess classic
comes down to a playoff between geary
and MBO who would your pic be uh really
doesn't matter to me you know i think i
think it's a little bit early be saying
that I think Magnus is a very good
chance of winning today so you know
we'll see what happens but you know well
we'll see but if it's playoff I mean I'm
dl's by far and away the better blitz
player but again it really does has no
bearing on my term or for my situation
so i'll just see what happens and
whatever well the holiday season is
coming up what is the best chess related
gift that you've ever gotten uh i don't
know i don't i don't tend to think about
chest during the holidays i think there
are many other things that are much more
important on so what let's just say i
haven't I haven't gotten many trust
gifts for for the holidays and I hope I
don't because I like I said I think
there are many much more important
things you know like family than done
trusted you know during the holiday
season so do not get Nakamura a chest
gift for Christmas alright guys you got
it back to you guys at the studio